good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 97 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
SCP 97 is contained within the limits of
the property where it was initially
discovered zone SCP 97 the property is
surrounded by an 8 metre tall concrete
block fence fitted with barbed wire and
security camera systems the satellite
images of zone SCP 97 are to be doctored
removing all traces of the area any and
all new plant growth outside the
containment area suspected to originate
from within the SCP is to be sterilized
through application of boiling salt
water and or incinerated absolutely all
abnormal behavior is to be reported to
dr. bridge within 10 minutes of the
occurrence if any personnel or their
families experience hallucinations or
thematically related dreams outside of
containment they are to contact dr.
Bridge to schedule treatment localities
surrounding SCP 97 specifically are to
be monitored from the 1st of April until
the 1st of November every year for
affected civilians medical
establishments dealing with sleep
abnormalities are to be monitored for
signs of SCP 97's influence civilians
below the age of 16 encountered alone
within one square kilometer of zone SCP
97 are to be taken into foundation
custody and are to be treated with a
Class B amnestic and returned home or
the nearest police station personnel
tasked with the return of civilians are
to avoid public exposure each agent is
to be assigned a cover story to follow
if they do encounter civilians on route
to their destinations sea level 3 staff
for details
the morning after the first frost of the
year a team of 25 agents armed with
agricultural tools are to enter SCP 97
and clear away the outer plant matter
this process is not to continue past
dusk description SCP 97 is a 10 acre
area of land in the state of in the
Midwestern United States it is the
abandoned remains of County Fair 1969 an
area of approximately 2.3 kilometers
squared the structures within the SCP
area exist in a state of moderate
disrepair consistent with the expected
age and environment at the center of SCP
97 lie the remains of a 1956 GMC pickup
truck the majority of which is crushed
beneath a colossal pumpkin of unknown
subtype henceforth SCP 9701 SCP 9701
stands approximately seven point four
meters tall and 8.1 meters in diameter
and its widest current estimates put SCP
9701 at approximately 15,000 kilograms
this pumpkin remains roughly spherical
in shape instead of spreading out under
its own weight
as would be expected of a plant of its
size the remaining portion of SCP 97 is
overgrown with several dozen varieties
of pumpkins with over 70 subspecies yet
identified and many previously unknown
to agriculture many of these pumpkins
have been shown capable of growing to
enormous sizes the average estimated
weight being around 250 kilograms these
pumpkins along with the other assorted
crops grow with on and around the
remains of the 1969 Fairgrounds creating
a maze-like arrangement of plant life
the average height of the walls within
scp-971 point six meters though this may
vary from year to year between April and
November each year the area within
scp-971 umber of anomalous phenomena
ranging from benign to implicitly
aggressive to date 17 agents have been
severely maimed within scp-971
the event log SCP 97 for a brief list of
recorded phenomena addendum historical
note prior to the construction of SCP 97
s containment wall instances of what are
now known as SCP 2171 1 were
occasionally observed to form fragmented
walls and at one point a near-complete
ring of 2171 around a CP 97's area of
effect this behavior ceased following
the containment walls completion the
purpose and implications behind this
interaction are as of yet unknown
effects of SCP 97 on children in
addition to its immediate effects
outlined in event log SCP 97 SCP 9701
appears to produce an undetectable
signal towards children in an
undetermined range for clarity children
will refer to individuals up to the age
of 10 beginning in early April civilian
children with SCP 97 s undefined range
may be overcome with some Nambu lism on
clear nights affected children will move
around their homes stopping to face
closed doorways for several seconds
before moving to the next nearest
doorway eventually returning to bed at
first this behavior will occur only once
a week beginning with only the doors on
a single floor this sleepwalking will
become more frequent by mid-august
happening every night if forcibly awoken
at any time during these episodes they
will scream for several seconds before
succumbing to a degree of confusion
after an affected child is awoken in
this manner the effect will cease and
the child will never show any further
signs of s AP 97 s influence
over the course of two to three months
these episodes will become more thorough
affected individuals seeking out each
doorway inside their home as well as
those on their households property such
as garages car doors and fence gates
eventually they will begin visiting the
front doors of neighbors beginning in
September affected children who have
remained undisturbed during these
episodes will begin to remain outside at
sunrise laying on grass near their
homestead and returning to full REM
sleep affected children may recall
dreams centering around autumn
activities between September 1st and
November 1st if the affected children
have not been awoken during the
proceeding sleepwalking episodes they
will cease the previously established
activity during the sleep walk and
instead begin to walk directly to Ward's
SCP 97's location they will travel over
fields and down secondary roads steadily
moving towards SCP 97 local geography
consists of mostly undeveloped
foundation owned property facilitating
uninterrupted travel upon arrival at SCP
97 an affected child will sit down
before SCP 9701 and begin singing
unidentifiable jibberish as music begins
to play while a number of instruments
have been recorded simple drums and
pipes are most consistently encountered
after several minutes childlike entities
will crawl out from tangled flora or
break out of larger pumpkins with NSC P
97 the children will be wearing whatever
they were last seen with most often
pajamas or similar clothing many of
these entities match those children
known to be lost to SCP 9701 the
entities will surround the affected
civilian child dancing and singing in a
circle as SCP 9701 begins to emit dim
light the affected child will awaken
normally expressing a great deal of
terror the instant any vocalization is
produced the entities will swarm and
kill the child
methods used are different in each
instance but usually involve
dismemberment or strangulation at this
point any and all efforts to interrupt
the entities will fail whether through
breakdown of equipment sudden and
tangibility of subjects or express
violence on the part of SCP 97 after the
death of the affected child SCP 9701
will split open and the entities will
hurl the remains into it before climbing
in themselves SCP 9701 will then close
and the music will stop before the
containment wall was erected at least
children between the ages of 3 and 10
are known to have been lost to SCP 97
see event log SCP 97 for current
examples of SCP 97 s behavior event log
SCP 97 this is a general incident log
for SCP 97 for the cycle between the 1st
of September and the 1st of November
this is an abridged version
please requisition full individual
reports from dr. bridge during this time
for civilian children were captured and
returned to their families
September 3rd 939 am cameras 3 B 4 a 4 C
and 5b View child approximately 4 years
of age walked between tangles of plant
matter to warns SCP 97 1 over an 8
minute period child appeared to be
dragging a stuffed animal notes child
appeared on footage during review period
no figure was viewed at the time of
recording September 5th 5:33 p.m. humans
scream heard from within a CP 97 heard
throughout the site on site personnel
described it as possessing a small
child's voice sustained for
approximately 3 minutes before stopping
abruptly notes staff reported feeling as
if they were being watched
during
then September 8th no time noted several
bed sheet ghosts are seen through
various security feeds throughout the
day would only appear for approximately
1 2 3 seconds before vanishing again
staff did not report seeing any
anomalous entities firsthand notes
Patrol's double-d's for the remaining
time in the SCP cycle September 13th
1019 p.m. unidentifiable singing is
heard throughout the site persisting for
three hours before becoming silent
recordings reveals song like gibberish
with up to 30 individual children's
voices singing at any time notes
recordings archived for future study
September 19th to 27 p.m. agent McRoy
cuts of pumpkins vine with a machete
severed vine proceeds to bleed
approximately 50 litres of human blood
before shriveling notes blood type a B -
no DNA match September 24th no time
noted overnight to separate pumpkin
patches grew into the rough
approximations of humanoid figures lying
on the ground notes destroyed without
incident
September 25th 5:17 a.m. agent long
found decapitated neck against the
pumpkin notes disappeared on route to a
bathroom break September 27th 2:50 a.m.
all light bulbs on site burn out within
a two minute period
notes critical areas repaired before
nightfall September 30th
12:16 p.m. sudden shift noted in the
location of several dozen gourd plants
notes time and nature of actual event
unknown
October 1st 2:29 p.m. agent Cole
accidentally damages and breaks pumpkin
during weekly examination of SCP 97
pumpkin splits open revealing a complete
human child skeleton in the fetal
position within notes female
approximately 5 years old no DNA match
October 2nd no time noted 29 freshly
decapitated crows found out scientist EP
97th containment wall notes none October
6th 637 am matured pumpkin plant found
to have replaced a hobbit plant growing
inside dr. bridges office notes indoor
plants banned from the site pumpkin
incinerated immediately October 7th 4:50
p.m. agent Matthews falls unconscious
during Patrol and cannot be awoken until
removed from property notes agent
reported dreaming of autumn colors and
the smell of leaves full recovery
reassigned to desk work pending
examination October 11th 7:30 8:00 a.m.
research assistants term reports
overwhelming taste and scent of pumpkin
permeating her senses no other personnel
report anomaly notes transferred
off-site examination pending October
13th no time noted sounds of steady
drums play throughout the day from 12
a.m. to 11:59 p.m.
notes sources sound unknown recordings
archived for future study October 17th
319 a.m. male child approximately 6
years of age and class
pajamas seen climbing through corn
stalks on the eastern end of SCP 97
moving towards SCP 9701 notes lost to
SCP 9701 how the child was able to
escape notice by personnel until after
he was lost to the SCP is unknown
October 20th 1:07 p.m. all personnel
within 3.6 kilometers of SCP 9701 report
hallucinations of orange haze and
children's laughter notes personnel
evacuated to a distance outside the area
of effect personnel screened for mental
interference October 23rd
12:01 a.m. all power and backup power to
the area failed upon recovery pumpkins
within SCP 97 were found to have changed
into carved lanterns notes it is unknown
how SCP 97 generated lit candles team 97
alpha and beta tasked to destroy
lanterns after sunrise October 23rd 8:13
a.m. team 97 alpha reports seeing and
hearing children playing among the flora
within scp-971 todays expected from the
reports notes children noted to be clad
in pajamas teams pulled from SCP
screened for mental interference October
25th
11:49 a.m. Z Mays and erotic kernels
fall from the sky around SCP 97 does not
fall within the containment walls notes
area cleansed with flame units and
replanted with non-native grasses
pavement outside of area pending October
26th 913 p.m. research assistant O'Toole
overcome with nausea and vomiting
concedes O'Toole did not eat pumpkin
seeds previous to vomiting notes
research assistant O'Toole transferred
to site for examination
seeds incinerated with prejudice
October 27th 10:03 a.m. research
assistant O'Toole reported to have died
overnight autopsy reveals thoracic
cavity was filled with pumpkin seeds
notes body incinerated its site
all personnel scheduled for full
physical examination October 28th no
time noted unintelligible whispering
gibberish heard by fertile female
personnel throughout the area when in
view of SCP 97 phenomenon continues
throughout the day continuing for the
duration of SCP 97 cycle ie until
November 1st notes Associated personnel
removed from duty and scheduled for
examination October 28th 5:45 p.m.
headlights of vehicle underneath SCP
9701 light and stay lit until daybreak
notes none October 29th no time noted
fruit trees within scp-971 over the
course of five hours beginning at
roughly 7:00 a.m. flowers wither and
fall soon after notes not October 29th
8:07 a.m. pumpkins near south entrance
to SCP 97 began spontaneously bleeding
from the stem each continued bleeding
for three hours
notes blood type a B - no DNA match
October 31st 3:10 a.m. several dozen
unidentified spheres of red light viewed
drifting above SCP 97 and surrounding
area when light was shot directly on the
spheres a piercing shriek was heard
notes personnel called into the main
building until spheres dissipated at
dawn October 31st 12:00 p.m.
sounds of steady drums are recorded from
within scp-971
notes no source identified recordings
archived for future study October 31st
to 19 p.m. all strawberry plants within
scp-971 in unison notes none October
31st
5:43 p.m. between 25 and 30 animate
human skeletons of varying size are
recorded breaking out of larger pumpkins
within SCP 97 skeletons traversed
through SCP 97 s flora to the northeast
peach tree and hang themselves from its
branches using lengths of grapevine
electrical cable and decaying rope
skeletons ceased anomalous behavior
after pantomiming death by hanging death
throes continued for approximately 23
minutes notes skeletons recovered after
first frost all appeared under 12 years
of age no DNA matches skeletons
incinerated after examination okay it's
just not Halloween unless a child
skeleton hangs itself huh anyway thank
you for listening if indeed you still
are and you were all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to permit the reclusive extrovert James
Saba arbiter Sewell Tyler Sean
Justin day Oh philia gray Durham Curie
kuma and jayvo Jack Jonathan Augusto and
dr. Proctor thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
you